that's how it happened okay i ain't
gonna get any more jewelry
like that my face
[Music]
what's your cutest dough boy you
watching on the rocks
i got this about a year ago it was a
gift from future
he gave it to me at the honey shooters
video with me him and me meal
and he got it personally engraved for me
and say brothers for life on the back of
it
straight from eliante soft hunter racks
you did
[Music]
right now my favorite piece it might be
it might be this one right here
this rbmg actually just got this the
other day
y'all made me do this and like you gotta
go through gq on the rocks and i'm like
you know what let me go grab this real
quick
it's like i've been had in the process
but i wouldn't even think about it for
hot and forgot
i just went to go pick this the other
day
i'm going to drop a cool quarter on it
real quick it's going to be something
that i just wear
every day like subtle now you know all
my pieces like my chains is like
it's big so it's like i need like calm
just like when i want to be chilling i
don't just look like i'm doing too much
all the time
crazy got to put gets in there then you
know just my label this rubber band
money game or bmg
it's white gold but it's wrapped with
like the gold rubber bands
in this chain i couldn't even tell you
what it is it was crazy i had to get it
it just looked so perfect you know i got
this from waffy
just the oh really you know that's my
signature ad lid
this might be my favorite channel this
is my favorite thing definitely you see
it got the doughboy bell on it
and it got the bezentine chain with the
baguettes going down the middle
and it's a chalk color chain it's white
rose and gold
feeling this is a cool 40. you got you
see you got the doughboy and gray dog on
the back
too
another fbg piece this piece presses to
me too
we got the cuban joint straight from
eliante this
original it was like 50. it's so crazy
i actually had to buy from somebody
that's in the game like i bought it from
somebody that's free ran
i bought it from one of the homies i'm
like man let me get that bird that's one
of the first birds
we gotta make and they're buying it from
one of the homes
this right here i actually i love this
ring like i don't even like wearing it
no more
nothing though this actually was a gift
too i got this from future
this rain special to me because this was
his first ring that he ever bought
like when he blew up this the first ring
he ever bought and he let me have
is right here cool little joint that i
might put on time to time
four thousand
[Music]
cool little ring pretty beautiful
about five thousand cool little star
about another five thousand
[Music]
it's a custom joint i got from status it
got
see this this over like like 30 carrots
in here
this centerpiece alone
see that booger
disrespectful
cool little rolly elegante made this too
sixty thousand see this this is a
byzantine it's a byzantine bracelet it's
actually matched master o'reilly chain
it was like like nine cds
little cuban joints feminists actually
it's four bracelets they just connected
these two is rose these two go eleante
too
[Music]
coming up who did you look at that
jewelry that influenced you
gucci of course it's my favorite like he
got the most ignorant
pieces of jewelry ever like that's what
i always wanted to grow up and get
big dumbass chains just like him
nowadays like i look at
pluto pink diamonds and they don't
understand they got millions and
millions and millions of dollars worth
of jewelry
he inspired me i'm trying to catch up
[Music]
oh yeah i almost forgot and i got
you know i got eight on the bottom i got
eight on the top i just don't i ain't
got it here right now
people be like they don't even get
permanent i don't want prominence i got
pretty teeth
i'm actually a matter of fact i'm about
to get my remote and i'm about to get
another one
i'm about to get another grill like you
see this one is like
gold white gold white every other tooth
gold and white
i'm about to get my redone if i get all
white
actually right now like in my motor
[ __ ] i might do that for y'all
careful thank you gq i appreciate you
having me and checking on my jury
collection
ain't nothing you almost thought i was
capping himself
i'm actually about to get my motor right
now
[Music]
it's going to take about 10 days we're
going to have an asap for you you know
what i'm saying because we're putting
them 1.7 points
big stones you know what i'm saying
gotta have it gotta have it all the way
together everything's gonna be clutching
and busting
big stone even bigger than mine my boy i
got you bro
appreciate it